(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] These
bubbles in the Baltic Sea
flared up after explosions on
the Nord Stream gas pipeline
since September, 2022.
The incident prompted several
international investigations.
Western officials initially
accused Russia of sabotage
while Moscow denied this.
Now more details of the
probes are starting to emerge.
- The German prosecutor announced
that they had searched a rental yacht
that was possibly linked to
the attack on the pipelines.
- [Narrator] They also
said a pro-Ukrainian group
may have been responsible,
but Ukrainian officials
denied any involvement.
So here's what we know so
far about the explosions
that hit some of Europe's
most important pipelines.
The Nord Stream and
Nord Stream 2 pipelines
were built to transfer
gas from Russia to Europe.
A Russian gas giant, Gazprom,
stopped deliveries through
Nord Stream in August, 2022
saying the pipes needed repairs.
Nord Stream 2 was built, but
wasn't up and running yet
because Germany stopped its certification
just before Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
Then in September, 2022,
the pipelines were damaged in explosions.
Germany, Sweden, and Denmark,
the three countries
closest to the incident,
launched separate
investigations into the cause.
Early findings said the
blasts were deliberate
and caused leaks in four places,
and the investigations
looked at the possibility
of Russia as the instigator.
Moscow has repeatedly
denied any involvement.
In early March,
German prosecutors said
that two months earlier
investigators searched a yacht
and found traces of explosives on board.
- We managed to locate it
in the north of Germany.
It's a very beautiful,
white, sleek leisure boat
that has five cabins and can
comfortably sleep 11 people.
- [Narrator] Investigators
believe the vessel set sail
from a port in northern
Germany on September 6th.
- Around September the 7th,
it made a pit stop in Wiek
on the island of Rugen,
also in northern Germany.
There, I think, part of
the crew came on board
and they loaded the boat with
food and other provisions.
And then from then there's a bit of a gap.
And then the boat reemerges
on the 16th of September
on the Danish island of Christianso,
which is close to the area
where the Nord Stream
pipelines were attacked.
- [Narrator] German officials
said a group of people
rented the boat.
Some of them presented Ukrainian passports
that may have been forged.
(speaking German)
- [Bojan] What we don't know, however,
is who these people were,
what is exactly their
relationship to Ukraine,
if they were Ukrainians,
and whether or not they
have any relationship
to the Ukrainian government or
any kind of formal authority.
- [Narrator] Ukrainian officials
denied any involvement.
- That's totally against our own interest.
- Russia's president had accused
what he called Anglo-Saxon powers
of blowing up the pipelines,
and the Kremlin said Western nations
rejected its request to
join their investigations.
- One thing that we know for a fact
that these investigators
do not believe anymore
that Russia was behind it.
- [Narrator] German
investigators are also looking at
whether the boat was
part of a larger mission
or a false flag operation
designed to divert attention
from the real culprits.
- We'll see where this leads,
but at the present time,
it doesn't seem we have more clarity.
It seems we have even more
layers of obscurity and mystery
adding to this kind of huge puzzle.
- [Narrator] The leaks highlighted
concerns about the safety
of critical energy
infrastructure in Europe.
- It demonstrates the importance
of protecting our critical
undersea infrastructure.
- [Narrator] As for the damaged pipes,
there's no indication that
they'll be repaired anytime soon.